jake arietta
makes his sixth start of the season
arietta two and three mark he's trying
to pitch the phillies to a sweep taking
on ronald acuna
swung on and hitting the air out towards
right field that'll drop in for a base
hit and cunha has a single and a lead
off single for ronald acuna dansby
swanson climbs in
and swansea pops it up into shallow
center field for roman quinn
garrieta's first down of the game brings
freddie freeman to the plate swung on
grounded towards first backhand
smothered by hoskins his only play will
be to get up and run to first
so two down and a runner at second no
score here's marcelo zuna
and then slowing away for ball four you
know the braves have a single from acuna
a walk to ozuna they're running at
runners at first and second with two
down for travis darnold swinging a
bouncer towards short gregorius has got
it easy play
fires it across and darno retired and
tommy malone on the mound for the first
time as a brave boy what a quick
transition it was from an oriole to a
brave the trade was made and the braves
were able to get him on a plane
and get him to philadelphia in time to
start tonight high fly ball to deep
center field
drifting back there towards the warning
track acuna squares his shoulders
and just in front of the wall makes the
catch one down and that'll bring rhys
hoskins to the plate
ground ball deep third it's a fair ball
past riley it'll go down the line and
hoskins around first he's headed for
second and reece had a big day yesterday
with three hits and he's got a double
here to start tonight
so they'll ring up bryce harper the
runner in scoring position
towering fly ball just back in the
infield cut out shallow right center
field and under johan camargo
two house runner at second for jt romuto
popped up
should be out number three under it is
dansby it's short looks up into the
philadelphia sky
makes a two-handed catch and down they
go one on one out now for austin riley
who's hit safely in eight of his last
nine
this one stroked out towards left center
field back there towards the gap and
that'll one hop the wall
rounding third and hanging to the plate
is duvall braves have the first tally of
the ball game leading one nothing here
in the second
jake arrieta used to just absolutely own
when he was at the height of the super
powers in 2015 and 16.
not to say that that still doesn't
happen it just doesn't happen with the
kind of regularity
arietta surrounded by braves with one
out on the top of the second inning for
dansby swanson
and that misses for ball four arietta's
walked in a run
austin riley scores two nothing braves
and the base is still loaded five
straight batters have reached base
against jake arrieta here
and here's freddie freeman swung on and
shot out to left field that'll drop in
for a base hit
this will score at least one run and now
bobbling it in left field is phil
gosling
a two-run double for freddie freeman
four-nothing atlanta
graves having some really good looks
versus arietta deep counts and if
they're not walking
they're making good contact marcelo zuna
chops one to the right side and that
gets right through rhys hoskins
picked up by scott kingery he tries to
dash to the bag and it's too late
a run scores and it's five nothing
braves and here comes joe girardi it
appears that's going to be the end of
the night for jake arrieta as joe
girardi is going to david hale
darneau is the ninth brave to the plate
here in the second inning ground ball
right side that's stung right on pass
rhys hoskins in a base hit
another run scored six nothing atlanta
here's nick markankus now
who led the inning off and marchakis
follows up with the ball into the same
spot
and nick marcakis clears the bases it's
now an eight
nothing ball game as the braves are
pounding the phillies here in the second
riley sends a ball to left that one is
crushed
and gone and it is ten
to nothing braves here in the second is
it over
ronald acuna junior is being removed
from the game for the braves
very smart decision you want to be safe
and dd gregorious at the plate swung on
and belted high in the air deep to right
marcake is drifting back to the track at
the wall looking up it's gone
solo shot for sir didi buddies are on
the board it's now 10-1
base hit for roman quinn to bring up
andrew mccutchen swung on and yank down
the left field line that's going to be
in for a base hit
quinn coming around third he's going to
score now ten to two ball game
getting closer and hoskin sends that one
to the left and that one's gone
a 10-0 lead has now become a
to 4 ball game the battle will be dd
gregorius
swung on rip down the right field line
long run marcakis towards the line and
it's going to be a fair ball
deedy on his way into third he's got a
stand up two run triple
and the phillies are back in this ball
game it's ten to
six and that is it for tommy malone his
braves debut stake to a ten
nothing lead luke jackson the new
pitcher for atlanta
and on the first [ __ ] he throws to phil
gosling another run comes
in to score and it's 10-7 atlanta good
runners at the corners with one away
well here's segura on the ground up the
middle and
pass swanson into center field hoskins
scores
and it's a two-run game ozuna the batter
with two outs and two on
swinging a ground ball pulled through
the whole left side of base in and it's
an rbi single for marcel
ozuna and it's 11-8 it's still the
braves 11 and the phillies eight
five outs to get here's roman quinn with
a drive to left
that one's gonna go and really go
and the phillies get one back it's now
11-9
mccutcheon sets the ball to right that
one's well hit
and that is good it's a one-run game
on back-to-back homers in the philly
half of the eighth
what a wild night this has turned into
it's inciarte to lead things off in
tonight gold
swing and a weak ground ball hit to
first and it's called a foul ball i
guess
it must have come off his foot joe
girardi comes running out of the dugout
he wants to talk to roberto ortiz
that ball did not hit the foot of ncrt
that should be a fair ball
joe now taking up his point with bill
welkey with crew chief joe girardi has
just been ejected from the game
swanson fly ball hit the center and hit
well quinn going back
at the wall that one's gone for dansby
swatson
and it's 12 to 10. and hit by a pitch
is real mucho so that'll bring the tying
run to the plate with nobody out in the
bottom of the ninth
here's gene segura he's got three hits
on the night three for four
another breaking ball on the ground to
shortstop
swanson to camargo back to freeman for
the double play
wow terrific play here gold glove
defense around the horn
that throw is offline and taking freddie
freeman into foul territory and he was
able to hang on and make that happen
with a terrific stretch so now it's dita
gregorius who represents the last chance
to keep things alive ground ball hit the
first backhanded by freeman
under heads to the cover in melanson and
the braves hold on grimly
at citizens bank park